meanwhile though we want to get back to
that breaking news here the metropolitan
police is to issue at least 30 more
fines for fixed penalty notices in
relation to breaches of cobit 19
lockdown rules in downing street in
whitehall it takes a number of fines now
to more than 50. let's cross back over
to westminster our political
correspondent ali fortescue is uh is
there for us and ali as we were
discussing a a very significant increase
in the total number
of referrals for fines from the met and
confirmation that the investigations are
ongoing and they're not done yet
yeah that's right so 20 fixed penalty
notices had been issued and now the met
police in the last half hour have told
us that they have made more than 50
referrals for fixed penalty notices that
means in the next couple of days we will
get more fines landing in more inboxes
as you say it is a big increase i think
it is damaging for the government to
have this drip drip of revelations it
will of course bring with it speculation
about who has got the fines last time we
saw helen mcnamara the sort of ethics uh
chief in government who was one of the
people that had a fine that brought
great criticism criticism too over the
timing some of the fines reportedly from
the day before prince philip's funeral
we will get that sort of speculation
again and of course speculation too
about whether the prime minister is one
of the people who has received a fixed
penalty notice there will undoubtedly i
think be nervousness in downing street
about that worth saying in the last
couple of moments i've just had a a
statement from the lib dems they say
that these fines expose the shocking
scale of the criminality responding to
the news that the police have made over
50 referrals
their leader ed davey said
that the police have now completely
shredded johnson's claims that no laws
were broken he cannot be trusted and
cannot continue as prime minister so
echoing their calls from the lib dems
for the prime minister to go i'm sure
we'll hear from labour shortly of course
the government line is they're going to
wait for this investigation to run its
course
before commenting further and they've
said that they will of course release
that sue grey report into all of this in
full once that happens
and ali just just remind us what's the
expectation in the short term even
before the full investigation is
finished are we likely to hear who those
extra 30 names are if indeed it is 30
different people uh or is the government
likely to remain tight-lipped on that
i think we will
not hear if they are civil servants
necessarily as we saw last time as i say
there was speculation the government
though have indicated that if the prime
minister is one of the people to get a
fixed penalty notice we will find out
about that so uh it will be interesting
to see what happens over the next couple
of days i think there will of course be
pressure and there has been pressure for
example for carrie johnson the prime
minister's wife to refer reveal if she
is one of the people who gets a fixed
penalty notice and i think the more
senior um the person the more pressure
they will there will be
we know that rishi sunak too
answered a questionnaire so we will see
whether there is
speculation reports confirmation of who
those people are who will be receiving
fixed penalty notices over the coming
days but for now we just have this
number 50 referrals over 50 referrals
that have been made fixed penalty
notices to the criminal records office
so as i say fines should be dropping
into email inboxes over the next few
days
investigations continue as well ali
thank you